. After quite literally years of pushing for
this, the issue of Donald Trump's taxes has
made it to the Supreme Court.
And the Supreme Court yesterday has cleared
the way for Donald Trump's taxes to be released.
Very important detail to be released to New
York prosecutors, not to the public or to
the House of Representatives.
You might remember that Donald Trump said
during the 2016 campaign that he would release
his taxes as soon as all of his audits were
over now.
In fact, it's been twenty two hundred days
almost since Donald Trump said he'd release
his tax returns.
He first said it in February of 2015.
He is not under if it's even true that he's
under audit.
Still, it wouldn't be for all of his years
of taxes, even if you believe that he shouldn't
release his tax returns while they are being
audited, which is a question he could release
the ones that are not being audited.
We don't know if there were any audits, but
it was all a lie in the sense that Donald
Trump never had any intention of releasing
his tax returns because he clearly calculated
he made the decision that whatever damage
would be done by not releasing them would
be vastly outweighed by the damage if he did
release them.
Well, now, after numerous appeals and legal
arguments, the Supreme Court says that indeed
the records might be shielded from public
disclosure.
But it is time for a Manhattan district attorney,
Cyrus Vance, to get those Trump tax returns
for the purposes of his investigations into
hush money payments made by Donald Trump and
other possible financial fraud.
So this finally is a step closer to prosecutors
getting the documents.
It may or may not be a step closer to these
documents being made public.
Now, we all know any time documents change
hands, the possibility of a leak becomes a
reality.
How likely these would be to leak from the
Manhattan D.A. when it would be known that
that's who had them?
That remains to be seen.
But it's happening.
There are no more appeals to make, as was
reported by NBC's Pete Williams on MSNBC yesterday,
quote, The New York grand jury will see Trump's
tax returns almost immediately.
This is the end of the road for the president.
So a few different things here.
It's absurd that it even took this long and
Trump kept appealing on different grounds.
And when a court would decide against him,
he would immediately appeal.
Again, it's gotten to the Supreme Court.
It took a long time.
Trump's not even in here.
He's been talking about releasing his tax
returns since before being in office.
He's now gone.
And this is only finally moving forward.
Now, whether we ever see the taxes at this
point, I don't know.
And it's less relevant.
It's more about whether Donald Trump can actually
get away with hiding his taxes forever and
from everyone.
And it seems that at least the from everyone
is becoming a hard no as prosecutors are going
to get them in.
The grand jury is going to look at them.
Now, as I've said before, Donald Trump's legal
expenses for the foreseeable future are going
to be formidable if he pays his lawyers, which
is always a caveat with Donald Trump.
And meanwhile, just as a reminder, there are
still conspiracy theorists, mostly of the
kuhnen persuasion, who believe that we are
just days from Donald Trump getting back in
office.
March 4th is the new date that many of them
have set.
They believe, as we've talked about a week
or two ago, that due to a technicality relating
to the fact that inauguration used to be on
March 4th before being moved to January 20th,
that somehow Donald Trump is going to go back
to power and back to being president on March
4th.
This decision by the Supreme Court for the
very conspiratorial types is an attempt at
interfering with Trump getting back in power
on March 4th.
How it has anything to do with it, I don't
know.
Obviously, Trump was never going to get back
in power on March 4th.
But when it doesn't happen on March 4th, many
of these Kuhnen types will say it was because
of this Supreme Court decision meant to.
I don't even know, but it's apparently a big
factor in what's going on, so we'll wait and
see on all of this stuff, including if and
when the tax returns ever become public.
The decision did cause Donald Trump to explode.
And that's what I want to talk
about next.